whenever somebody does something so much
better than everybody else whether it's
a competitive thing or otherwise it's
natural to ask what did they do that's
so different so we tell the story of
Takeru Kobayashi who you may recognize
his name as the best maybe slightly
disputed now but a great hot dog eating
champion when he competed in his first
nation's famous fourth of July Coney
Island hot dog eating championship the
world record was 25 and 1/8 hot dogs and
buns in 12 minutes and his first
competition and guys have been competing
for many 40 years or so so you know it
wasn't an overnight thing and his first
contest eating hot dogs
he didn't just win and he didn't just
set a new world record but he doubled
the old record 50 hot dogs and buns in
12 minutes so naturally you would ask
how could he be so so so much better was
he an anatomical freak or was there
something in his methodology and his
protein in his strategy and so on that's
what we set out to find out we spent a
lot of time talking to him about his
approach and it turns out that what he
did was he looked at the way all the
past competitors were doing it which was
basically you have a pile of hot dogs
and you pick one up two hands eita and
then fast as you can that allowed slug
down some water swallow and then keep
going as fast again Hey look that I
thought is that really the right way to
solve that problem or to attack that
challenge and he thought maybe but not
necessarily and so he decided to kind of
break it down and try to experiment from
top to bottom and in think like a freak
we write a lot about the need for
experimentation experimentation can give
great feedback great answers a lot of
people are scared of experimentation
because they think you have to be a
scientist or they're also scared of
because it means that you have to admit
that you don't know the answer a lot of
people like to assume they know the
solution to a problem when they don't
but experimentation can really you know
set you up to learn the real answer so
he tried a lot of different things not
all them worked many didn't he found
that if he broke the dog in two pieces
before he ate that would help just a
little bit
to start because he's first of all doing
one move with his hands that he doesn't
use mouth for so he's starting to speed
up there and then he found that he liked
to separate the dog from the bun and he
found that he could eat each faster that
way the dog actually goes down fairly
easy because it's dense and salty and
slick the bun it's actually airy and
kind of hard that's why they were hard
to chew together so then he found that
if he soaked the bun in warm water
before eating them and squeezed out the
excess water then he could make a kind
of bun ball pop that in that goes down
now you might think we'll wait a minute
why would you want to take on excess
water when you're trying to eat as many
hot dogs as you can turns out however
that there was a benefit to this idea
which was in addition to making it
faster which was that he was now getting
liquid down his system without having to
stop after eating each hot dog and drink
so he's constantly making his process
more efficient he's videotaping his
training sessions he's recording all
this data and analyzing it in a
spreadsheet he's experimenting with pace
he's experimenting with sleep he's
experimenting with weight training and
when it came time to compete for the
first time he blows everybody's mind and
doubles the world record so you could
say well this is just a nice albeit
silly I'll be a disgusting story about
some guy who did something better than
everybody else and that's fair enough
but we make a couple conclusions from it
the first is that what he really did
that I think can be applied to any kind
of problem is he redefined the problem
he was trying to solve so all the other
eaters were basically asking themselves
this question how can I eat a lot of hot
dogs in 12 minutes right that's kind of
the natural conventional question that's
a very different question maybe not very
different subtly different question that
led to an entirely different result
which was how can I eat one hot dog
faster and by asking a different
question he came up with the entirely
different set of answers I'm gonna break
it and separate the dog from the bun I'm
gonna soak the bun in water I'm gonna do
all this different stuff so what he did
in our view is he redefined the problem
he was trying to solve and as we write
and think like a freak a lot of the
problems that we all set out to solve as
society whether they're
keishon problems or famine poverty any
kind of policy problems we often think
we're going for the real problem or the
underlying problem when in fact we're
not we're often a trap we're often
attacking kind of a symptom or the part
of the problem that bothers us and
sometimes you really need to redefine
the problem you're trying to solve in
order to ask a better question like Kobe
did to get better answers the other
lesson that I think we can draw from the
Kobayashi success story has to do with
limits and the limits that we are
willing or unwilling to accept and what
I mean by that is this there we all face
limits every day in our lives there's
financial limits time limits limits of
what's socially acceptable and so on and
you know we're mostly pretty you know we
mostly adhere to them there are however
a lot of limits that we argue are not
legitimate or they're artificial
barriers and in this case of taki rule
Kobayashi and the hot dogs
there was this existing limit or barrier
at least a record a world record of 25
and 1/8 before he came along so I asked
him once you know how did you think you
could break that record your first time
out and he said oh I didn't pay any
attention to that world record we said
why not it was you know the world record
of this big contest he said because I
knew that the other eaters before me
were asking the wrong question about
eating hot dogs then I knew that the
record wasn't legitimate and so he
literally kind of divorced from his mind
the idea that this existing record
existed 2500s now you could say woody of
still could have still broken the world
record if he had treated that old record
as legitimate maybe but in our view it's
hard to imagine that he would have
doubled the world record 50 if he had
honored the legitimacy of that existing
record so we argued that that was in his
mind an artificial barrier the old world
record he wasn't going to accept it by
refusing to accept it he beat it by a
mile and we argued that we should all
look around at our situations work
family politics whatever
look at what we think are real barriers
and where they may not be real where
they may be artificial and the next time
you come up against an artificial
barrier at work when someone says you
know this is the way we do this project
because that's the way it's always been
done or this is as much as we can expect
to do or this is as good as we can
expect to be if you think that barrier
is not legitimate credible it's
artificial let's throw it away throw it
as far as you can get on with your own
thing and think like a freak that's
really the idea